[Music]
Samsung assistant built its newest
smartphones the eye tech giant revealed
the galaxy s 9 and s 9 plus yesterday
and we've got one at the table just
before the start of the Mobile World
Congress in Barcelona so the new
features include camera technology that
lets people take quality pictures in
low-light settings upgrades to the
virtual assistant Bixby and an enhanced
audio system the starting price is just
under seven hundred and twenty dollars
pre-orders began this Friday and the new
models go on sale March 16th Dan
Ackerman from our partners at CNET joins
us at the table to discuss so Dan
starting price just under seven hundred
twenty dollars that's still pricey
cheaper though than the iPhone 10 which
was $9.99 it is and that phone started
the entry price for that phone was $9.99
I think I've scared a lot of people off
yeah Samsung I think probably looked at
this and said we have to pull it back a
little bit the smaller phone the s9 is
like 719 or 729 and the bigger phone the
s9 plus is eight hundred and thirty nine
dollars they'll cost a little bit
differently depending on which carrier
you get it is the camera the big selling
point for a lot of these is really the
camera these days and the upgrades for
this phone the s9 over the previous
version is definitely
improvements to the camera because
people use these as cameras probably
more than they use them as phones what
about this personalized emoji technology
that was super fun
just like on the iPhone 10 they have the
van emojis that turn you into an animal
on here they have got a are emojis I'm
gonna see if I can create one here okay
I'm gonna flip the camera round so it's
looking at you
neutral neutral ish face neutral face
okay and it's doing it and there we go
cranking away well that's cuz she's
usually smiling so there look at that
I can I can move this around in 3d and
then I can change the outfits and I can
change the hairstyle and then I can save
that into a whole bunch of little
animated gifts that you can send people
where you can record little video
messages with can you do John so we can
see the boy version I know I know let's
see we can do that too so is this
reality emoji sort of a response to
apples animo
I mean this is clearly their version of
the an emoji that Apple has that turns
you into an animal this turns you into
an actual version of yourself but the an
emojis work really great because Apple
has that 3d sensing we need a woman to
do this - they're gonna flip it around
and we're gonna do here we go and that's
the battery power the battery and all
these phones is is is pretty decent but
the big secret is whether it's an iPhone
or Samsung phone get the larger of the
two phones the s-line plus or the eight
and your Diner usually isn't that dark
no well today I'm trying something a
little lighter and so in this case the
emoji is punishment for something I seem
to have done right and now will live on
forever yeah mailing it to each other
for years to come
Dan how does it stack up against the
iPhone 10 because right now does Samsung
sell more than iPhones globally they
ship more phones than Apple does but
it's really you know the two big titans
almost anyone especially in the US
market who's getting a smartphone is
either getting an iPhone or Samsung
phone do you think people will switch
from the iPhone of any any version for
this that's the toughest thing because
these phones have such you know complex
ecosystems once you're into one and you
get an iPhone one year and an Apple
watch and a macbook and an ipad or a
samsung phone and the samsung smart
watch samsung also makes excellent
laptops it's tough to convince people to
switch you might switch between
different brands of Android phone but
going from iOS to Android it's tough to
convince people to scale when you give
this a what we have not fully tested it
out yet but it certainly seems you know
very impressive it's definitely the big
phone of the year at least until the
fall when we see what Apple is going to
do all right Stan break it down